CHARGES.
SO THERE WE ARE IN THAT.
>> Tucker: THERE WE ARE ON
THAT.
BRIT HUME, GREAT TO SEE YOU.
SUGGESTING THAT RUSSIA AND OTHER
COUNTRIES HAVE BEEN MEDDLING IN
THE COUNTRY FOR SOME TIME, THERE
IS AN OBVIOUS QUESTION THAT HAS
BEEN DISMISSED, BUT A REAL ONE,
WHAT ABOUT THE LAST
ADMINISTRATION?
THEY KNEW ABOUT THIS.
WHY DID THEY NOT DO ANYTHING
ABOUT IT?
WHERE WAS THE FBI, THE EDITOR AT
LARGE FOR DailyMail.com, WE
ARE HAPPY TO HAVE THEM TONIGHT.
PIERS MORGAN, YOU ARE LOOKING AT
THIS FROM AN ADVANTAGE, AND YOU
THINK OF THEM AS A LAW
ENFORCEMENT IT ALWAYS GETS ITS
MAN, HAVE YOU REVISED YOUR TAKE
ON THE FBI OVER THE LAST YEAR?
>> WELL, I'VE REVISED IT IN THE
LAST WEEK, ONE OF THE WORST EVER
WEEKS AND THE FBI AND ITS 198
YEARS OF HISTORY.
I WILL TELL YOU WHY, TWO
REASONS.
TAKE THE RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION.
DONALD TRUMP IS PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES NOW AND HAS BEEN
FOR OVER A YEAR, BUT THERE
REMAIN ZERO EVIDENCE THAT SAYS
THAT HE COLLUDED WITH ANYONE
FROM RUSSIA IN AN ATTEMPT TO FIX
THE U.S. ELECTION.
NOW MUELLER MAY HAVE SOME SECRET
EVIDENCE, BUT HE IS NOT PROVIDED
IT.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE WITH TRUMP
TO ANY COLLUSION.
WELL, OKAY, WE KNOW THAT IT IS
RUSSIAN MEDDLING, WE DO NOT KNOW
THE SCALE.
BUT IT MAY BE REASONABLY SMALL
AND NOT THAT SIGNIFICANT.
BUT THERE WAS MEDDLING, YOU
WOULD EXPECT THAT.
BUT WHOSE JOB WAS THAT IT TO
DEAL WITH THE MEDDLING?
THAT WOULD BE THE PREVIOUS
PRESIDENT, BARACK OBAMA WHO FROM
2014 WHEN THE MEDDLING STARTED,
IT WAS HIS JOB AND ON HIS WATCH.
AND HE HAS 17 INTELLIGENCE
AGENTS LED BY THE FBI, AND IT IS
THEIR RESPONSIBILITY, IN MY VIEW
TO INVESTIGATE AND TO STOP AND
TO CLOSE DOWN THE KIND OF
USE RUSSIANS.
AND THAT SIMPLY DID NOT HAPPEN.
SO I WOULD SAY IF YOU COMBINED
THAT PERFORMANCE BY THE FBI IN
TERMS OF THE RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION OR LACK OF IT THAT
WAS GOING ON, AND THEN YOU LOOK
AT WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE MASS
SHOOTING THIS WEEK IN FLORIDA.
THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST
SPECTACULAR BALL DROPS THAT I
HAVE EVER SEEN FROM ANY
INTELLIGENCE AGENCY.
THE FBI WERE WORN TWICE.
ONCE THAT THIS GUY POSTED ON A
BLOG OR COMMON TREE THAT HE WAS
NIKOLAS CRUZ, SPELT IN A UNUSUAL
WAY.
THEY WERE NOT ABLE TO TRACE
HIM, AND HE HAD A BLOCK
AROUND -- BACKGROUND CHECK.
THEY COULD'VE FOUND HIM IN
5 MINUTES.
FOUR MONTHS TO THE START OF
JANUARY, AND THEN WE HAVE THE
MOST EXTRAORDINARY SITUATION
WHERE IT TURNS OUT TO THAT
SOMEBODY VERY CLOSE TO THE
SHOOTER PHONED THE FBI TIP LINE
DESIGNED FOR TIPS ABOUT CRIME
AND POTENTIAL CRIME AND SAID
THAT THIS GUY IS DANGEROUS, HE
IS HEAVILY ARMED.
WE THINK THAT HE MAY SHOOT UP
THE SCHOOL.
AND TO THE FBI DID NOT EVEN
REFER IT TO ITS HEAD OFFICE IN
MIAMI.
IT DID NOT EVEN SEE IT DESPITE
HAVING TWO WARNINGS THAT THIS
GUY MIGHT BE ARMED, DANGEROUS,
UNSTABLE, MENTALLY ILL, AND
PREPARED TO SHOOT A SCHOOL UP.
PUTTING THOSE TWO THINGS
TOGETHER, AND I'M SORRY, THIS IS
A PRETTY POOR PERFORMANCE BY THE
FBI LEADING ME TO CONCLUDE IN MY
COLUMN TODAY THAT WILL BE BETTER
OFF CALL THE CALLING THEM THE
FEDERAL BUREAU OF INCOMPETENCE.
>> Tucker: I THINK YOUR
INTERPRETATION IS RIGHT, YOU ADD
TO THAT TO THE LAS VEGAS
SHOOTING, WE HAVE NO
UNDERSTANDING OF WHY THAT
HAPPENED, AND THERE IS A TRAIL
OF INCOMPETENCE BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT, SO HERE'S MY
QUESTION, GIVEN ALL OF THAT, I
THINK YOUR POSITION IS A
REASONABLE ONE, WHY IS THAT THE
PEOPLE WHO SAY THAT ARE
DENOUNCED AS UNPATRIOTIC BY
MEDIA FIGURES?
WHY IS IT UNPATRIOTIC TO
QUESTION FEDERAL AGENTS?
>> IT IS INTERESTING, ISN'T IT?
I THINK THE PARTISAN NATURE IS
SO EXTREME ON BOTH SIDES TO A
LARGE DEGREE.
THE ANTI-TRUMP THEORY IN
PARTICULAR MEANS THAT PEOPLE ARE
NOT ABLE TO SEE THE WOODS
THROUGH THE TREES.
I COME FROM A DIFFERENT COUNTRY,
I COME TO THIS WITH A CLEAR OPEN
MIND.
I WROTE 36 COLUMNS ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP TO DAILY MAIL LAST
YEAR.
18 WERE SUPPORTED IN 18 WERE
CRITICAL.
AND THE REASON IS IMPARTIAL
VOICE IN THE DEBATE.
I WOULD SAY TO ALL OF THOSE WHO
DO NOT WANT ANY CRITICISM OF
BARACK OBAMA TO WHAT HAPPEN WITH
THE RUSSIAN MEDDLING OR WITH THE
FBI TO THE MEDDLING IN THE
INVESTIGATION INTO THE SHOOTER,
TAKE A GOOD LONG LOOK AT
YOURSELVES, BECAUSE IF THIS
HAPPENS WITH DONALD TRUMP, LET'S
REVERSE IT.
LET'S SAY THAT DONALD TRUMP HAD
BEEN THE PRESIDENT WHEN ALL OF
THIS MEDDLING WAS ACTUALLY GOING
ON.
AND WE KNEW IT WAS GOING ON.
THERE WILL BE ABSOLUTE OUTRAGE
THAT HE HAD NOT STOPPED IT.
SO IT IS LEGITIMATE TO LOOK AT
BARACK OBAMA AND SAY, WHERE WERE
YOU WHEN THIS MEDDLING WAS
HAPPENING ON YOUR WATCH?
AND THE ANSWER IS THAT HE AND
THE FBI SEEMED FAR MORE
EXERCISED TO BE INVESTIGATING
OTHER TECHNOLOGY IN TERMS OF
EMAILS, HILLARY CLINTON,
SERVICES ON, QUITE LEGITIMATELY.
BUT WHERE THEY BASICALLY TAKING
THEIR EYE OFF THE BALL AND NOT
FOCUSING ON WHAT IS PROBABLY FOR
THE AMERICAN COUNTRY FAR MORE
SERIOUS, WHICH IS THE SISTER
RUSSIA MEDDLING THROUGH AMERICAN
COMPANIES LIKE FACEBOOK,
TWITTER, GOOGLE, AND OTHERS,
USING AND IF LUCIDLY MEANT
DIFFUSING THEM TO INTERRUPT TO
THE THINKING.
>> Tucker: YOU CANNOT ARGUE
SIMULTANEOUSLY THAT THERE WAS A
BIG DEAL AND OBAMA IS BLAMELESS.